Well Steph congratulations how much do
you live for these late game pressure
moments probably shouldn't ask me to we
already know the answer to that listen
so much adversity that you've already
faced this season and in this game alone
you lose a starter you had to play with
foul trouble the entire fourth quarter
in overtime plus it felt like there was
an actual lid on the rim how did you as
a team overcome it
all I mean uh that was that was probably
the most grit and uh determination we've
shown all year like you said down a lot
of guys uh CP playing in Crazy minutes
Trace Jackson Davis coming
in a week ago he wasn't in the rotation
uh and he comes in makes a huge
difference JK is playing great defense
all games play big shots so it was I
mean obviously a total team effort but
the belief that we have like we haven't
had a lot of results to show for it this
year but the belief that we showed
tonight it's nice to to get uh to get a
big win like that also you were without
your part partner in crime and Draymond
Green you changed up your shooting
routine pregame a few games ago you're
coming off the first time since 2018 you
didn't hit a three when you saw that big
three go down what was that feeling like
for you I mean Big Shot obviously to try
to seal it knowing how hard we fought to
come back overtime like we played the
same Five Guys for seemed like uh 17
straight minutes so for us to dig deep
and get that win no matter how we get it
done like we want to be
a playoff Contender and these are the
type of games that uh you know show us
that we can be that we just got to keep
putting them together take a deep breath
and enjoy it thanks so much Steph
absolutely shout out to my guy rker you
gave me some love early in the game so I
appreciate you absolutely oh I love it
Riker's a star already
Reginal